[Music]
imagine if by just slightly adapting an
existing technology you could supply the
world's electricity needs 11 times over
now it's really tiny
but the potential is huge the results we
have seen is kind of is exceeding our
expectations developers are taking wind
turbines to deep water where previously
they couldn't
and instead of building them onto the
sea floor they'll float on the surface
you're able to go much deeper into the
ocean and thus catch more of the wind
that's available
floating platforms could open vast new
areas of the ocean to wind power
generating billions of dollars in
turbine contracts but also
valuable clean energy
if you could do floating wind in an
industrial manner then you could really
do something that might be an important
factor in the fight against climate
change the race is on to develop
cost-efficient floating farms that can
become an almost boundless source of
emission-free electricity
and there are already dozens of players
competing to make the best design
feel a big pressure
for us to succeed not for the sake of
our company
but for the sake of
making the green transition happen
[Music]
most of the world's energy today still
comes from fossil fuels that's coal oil
and gas
none of those fossil fuels are on their
way out as quickly as we need them to to
be able to meet global climate goals
since the 70s wind power has been on a
slight rise but it's really taken off in
the last decade or two decades
one of the things that has made wind
power more cost effective in recent
decades has been the increasing size of
the wind turbine
they went from something you could look
at without having to even turn your head
up to almost the size of the empire
state building now
the reason big turbines matter is
because of something called the power
equation which is the square of the
radius of the turbine which covers its
area and the wind speed cubed for every
increase in the radius there's a factor
more wind power that can be caught from
the wind speed as wind turbines get
bigger they go higher into the sky
and the higher they go the faster the
wind that they can catch and all of that
helps make wind turbines that are bigger
much more effective at being able to
produce power
putting more turbines out at sea where
the wind blows stronger and more
consistently could mean generating even
more energy more cost effectively
that means seriously modifying the
designs of current turbines
so when i set out to
see if i could
make a difference i looked at existing
designs
and i looked at
so to speak the the mechanisms that were
driving them
oh now there will be some the clocks
will
chime
that's a classical english grandfather
clock very very nice that one will do it
and that one will do it hamrich stiesdel
is very fond of clocks
and the one over there is a french
middle piece clock from
that one is from the 1700s that's from
the 1800s the one in there from the
1700s
he likes their qualities accuracy
simplicity longevity
and of course there's something sexy
about the machine
that has been running for 250 years
that's sort of that's well done
the danish inventor is also very aware
of time and that one day it'll run out
he's become a renewable energy pioneer
working with wind power since he was a
boy
my father said let's go up and see
a place where they're building a big
wind turbine
so we went up and took a look at that
and and i saw young people like myself
at that time i was
i was 19 and i thought well if they can
do it i can do it also
and after some experiments we found an
aerodynamic shape
that worked tremendously
you go out with this kind of dead thing
and set it in motion
and then when it started spinning it
felt as if it got alive because it could
feel all the small areas in the wind in
a completely different way from when it
was standing still and then i was hooked
after that i built a larger test turbine
and then i ended up building a turbine
that would power in my parent's farm
known as the godfather of wind steisdell
is linked with most of the industry's
big firsts patenting the three-blade
turbine that's ubiquitous today and
launching the very first offshore wind
farm in the world off the coast of
denmark
after working for some of the sector's
biggest players he retired briefly
he's been tempted back to find solutions
for a power hungry world
and there i landed on the idea that the
combination of
floating offshore wind which is the only
way you can do offshore wind in
california and to a large extent the
most important you can do in japan so
you don't always have the the space
available for
onshore wind you might not have the
space available for solar
but with offshore wind
you generally have enough space but
there the challenge is that it only
works up to about 60 meters of depth or
something of that nature
building foundations in the seabed
deeper than this makes turbines too
expensive and so offshore turbines are
only built in relatively shallow water
[Music]
so one of the reasons why
the offshore wind industry has done so
well in europe is because the continent
is blessed with a continental shelf that
extends into shallow waters for hundreds
of kilometers from the coastline
that's not the case for most parts of
the world california for example has
very deep waters very close to its
coastline which means they cannot use
offshore wind turbines as a solution for
their electricity needs and that's where
floating winter events can make a real
difference because they provide an
option that hasn't yet existed in an
economical fashion for tapping wind
power
offshore wind can supply the
whole electricity demand of the world as
it is now
but it is fairly unevenly
distributed
with many places not being able to
exploit also when because they just
don't have the ocean conditions for it
if you
instead introduce floating or in
parallel introduced floating you can
multiply the
available resource by a factor of 10.
making a wind turbine the size of the
empire state building float out in the
ocean is easier said than done
wind turbines are not cheap they use
expensive metals there are magnets there
are
those blades which have been you know
hundreds of meters long which have been
constructed specifically for that
purpose
so when you put a floating wind turbine
out into the sea you want to be very
sure it will not fall over the simple
idea behind a floating wind turbine is
that you need enough buoyancy
to keep the wind turbine erect and above
water and you can achieve that with a
simple idea like the boat's hull where
you put a certain amount of weight under
water that provides the buoyancy to keep
it erect and catch the wind
this is exactly what dozens of floating
wind designs try to do many use the
principles of a floating boy to build a
spa
a tube-like marine structure that relies
on gravity for stability
it's then tethered to the sea floor
one of schtesdale's designs tetraspa
uses several modular steel tubes
so you've got three radials we call them
three laterals and three diagonals and
what the diagonals do
is that they help
transfer the big bending moments on the
tower in a smart way out to the
structure so that's why we call it tetra
spa it's a tetrahedron as a geometrical
shape and it's a spa because it works
with this center of gravity below the
center of buoyancy
it stretches some 165 meters into the
it's got a rotor
that's 130 meters in diameter the
floater itself weighs more than a
thousand tons and
is 60 meters from one side to the other
it can move about 30 or 40 meters
away from its its neutral position when
it has the full load on the rotor it
will heal over about 5 degrees the
turbine is a 3.6 megawatt turbine
that is a small turbine nowadays because
the industry is developing so fast if
things work out as they should
it will generate about 14 million
kilowatt hours a year well in my home we
used about 4 000 kilowatt hours a year
so this turbine will power about three
and a half thousand homes like my home
so even though it is by modern standards
a small turbine still is something that
you can see that's kind of interesting
a town with
three and a half thousand households
is not a small village and one turbine
can power that
building smart green technologies will
help save our planet
but to make a real impact we need to
burn fewer fossil fuels
offshore wind is an important bridge one
industry that has benefited from the
offshore wind industry has actually been
the oil and gas industry because they
have a lot of technology but also skills
and experience working with offshore
platforms drawing out oil and gas
some of those skills can be applied to
offshore wind power and to floating wind
power which means there is actually a
route available at least for some people
to be able to transition from what is a
carbon-heavy job to a low-carbon job in
the future something that the world is
going to need if it's going to
transition away from fossil fuels
norway's equinox is undergoing that
massive transition formerly stat oil the
company produces more than two million
barrels of oil a day and is the second
largest supplier of natural gas in the
european market
but it's made big strides into
renewables
and it's also arguably leading the pack
when it comes to floating wind
their design is called high wind it's
based on the simple spa principle
something the oil and gas industry has
already been using to float platforms
this location is excellent for building
a high winds bar and the reason why it's
it's sheltered areas is deep water areas
close to shore ecuador has been a
pioneer within floating winds since the
early 2000s when we developed and
installed the hiven demo back in 2009
equinol's design is in use in a fully
operational five turbine farm off the
coast of scotland
it's proving the technology's worth
through higher than average capacity
factors that's the share of time the
turbine produces electricity at peak
capacity
the higher the number the more value for
money
the hive in scotland has been the best
ever producing turbine with a capacity
factor of 57 at maximum for for several
years
the newest developed bottom fixed
projects and
farms has higher capacity factors maybe
in the high 40 percents but for sure
hive in scotland has proved that putting
floating wind turbines in areas where
you have a good wind condition it's very
favorable for floating offshoring
from hive and demo to ivan scotland we
see a cost decrease from carpets per
megawatt of sixty percent from hive in
scotland to having tampering we're
aiming for a cost reduction between 40
and 50
in norway another 11 floating devices
are being constructed
once complete they'll be towed out to
deep water
the energy the turbines produce will
help power the company's oil and gas
platforms some of the region's biggest
ecuanor says it will reduce co2
emissions by 200 000 tons a year
we will build our legacy from oil and
gas and
projects execution marine operations
and that's why we went into bottom
fixture wind and now floating off
showing that we can use our competence
or experience and for sure we can also
finance
these new developments within renewables
because the cash flow we have from oil
and gas
that's another advantage the oil and gas
giants have this 11 turbine project is
set to cost equino an estimated 600
million dollars
within this decade we shall invest
as much in renewables as we do in oil
and gas it's not the proving of the
concept we have proved it so this is
kind of just the next stepping stone and
then we go for this industrialized we
inform
the cost battle will be the most
challenging one to make this industry
profitable and then we need big volumes
there is a lot of things which need to
happen at the same time
equinor has ramped up production in
norway by building its own on-site
cement factory it's an attitude of
industrialization that could quickly
determine floating winds key players
among the dozens of floating wind
turbine designs that are out there one
of the ways in which the winner might be
chosen is based on
how much material is used in the
development of those designs so the
lower the amount of material used the
lower the cost of that floating wind
turbine is likely to be
so wind power has gone from being a
costly alternative to being something
that is nowadays competitive with fossil
power sources say why
the main driving factor was
industrialization
so mass production is the way to low
cost
i have a mobile phone somewhere i don't
have it here but i have it somewhere i
paid maybe
six hundred dollars for it
and as you know everybody knows it's got
the like hundred times a thousand times
the computing power that nasa had when
they said people to the moon if i was to
build that one from scratch it would not
cost 600 it would cost 6 million or
whatever the reason i can get something
with all that power is because it's mass
produced and that's also what has come
into wind power
prices kept dropping dropping dropping
because we produce things in big numbers
we have designed a structure that is
modules that are built in the factory in
the right length so that when you have
this piece of steel plate you can roll
it into what we call a can
and then you simply
weld it
where it got rolled together
and then you put it together with
neighbors and weld them all together
with a round seam
and getting that to work is what vulcan
is super good at
and then they are transported to the
port
and in the port they are assembled
and then the floater is launched you put
on the turbine and tow down to the side
as with any technology in its nascency
it feels a little fanciful to imagine
what a world full of that new technology
would look like
but we've seen that happen time and
again with solar panels batteries and
electric cars so there's no reason to
think that can't happen with floating
wind turbines beyond 2030 i believe
strongly believe that we will see big
scale wind farms which is profitable and
we will see also that the ramping up
that this will be a big industry going
towards 2014 and 2050.
[Music]
if you were to do theoretical
calculations pretty much any type of
renewable energy will be able to provide
all the power that the world needs
be that building solar panels in the
middle of sahara and then cabling the
world with them or building
say floating wind turbines in the middle
of the pacific and doing the same so
there isn't a limit on how much power
renewable energy can provide what is the
limit is how much money we can spend to
be able to access that power
the competition in floating wind could
be brutal inevitably some companies will
lose out and maybe go bust
for now the competition can only be a
good thing
we cannot create all the volumes we need
also volumes from our competitors
so we we think that this competition is
important for for industrializing
floating offshoring
it could be that there could be several
of them who simply outsmart us and do it
in a better way and that would be okay
because what we are doing this for is
for the climate
so if somebody comes in and out competes
or outsmarts us and says yeah i heard
what you said i kind of agree on the
industrialization way i just found a
smarter way to do it he or she would be
my friend
you